captain's log final entry
Spock and I are the sole survivors
enterprise are you there morning Wendy
morning Scotty can we go over your
everyday schedule wake up go to work
welcome to Cinnabon would you like us
into on our script coming I just wrote a
story where Spock travels to deep space
9 that's how awesome 3 p.m.
take Pete for a walk 6 p.m. watch Star
Trek before I go to bed your script
highlighting the best of the Star Trek
universe next week your sister is coming
there's a Star Trek script writing
contest we can go to the post office and
then we can go home with you please
stand by breathe here completed script
must be received by February 16 where're
you going Los Angeles bus driver my
friend needs to pee
don't do it Pete this is what happens
when you pee on the bus we're going down
LA maybe he's just kind of bet she's 5
foot 4 blonde that's her I know he's the
hero of Star Wars really exactly is this
a Kirk person she's out there alone
she's a very resourceful girl
where am I you're at the hospital you
hit your head out the window get away
from you people
now dab your horse not therefore you
ghost
well language is that it's Klingon your
sister is one of the most complex and
creative people I know people have their
own lives and after a while those lives
don't include you captain there's only
one logical direction in which to go
forward
light it can travel for millions of
years before finally reaching its
destination do you know how hard it is
to write something because the story you
want to tell me so much to you
it goes lonely and alone hoping that it
will reach someone that's amazing so
what happens next the unknown is there
for us to conquer not to fear who's
Leonard McCoy's daughter's name
Joana oh snap pay up
you